- I'd like you to give
a please warm welcome
to not only my friend,
but someone who's really
changed the world, RuPaul.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
- I thought you were talking about Cher.
(RuPaul laughs)
Hi baby, hi!
(audience cheers)
(RuPaul laughs)
In Hollywood!
Wow, hello everybody!
Look at you! You're gorgeous.
- I curtsy and I bow.
Sit down.
- What gorgeous chairs, it's
like, we're coordinated here.
We are what? Coordinated.
Ladies and gentlemen, yes, I love it.
Fabulous.
- Well, great minds thinking alike
and the Emmy's are this Sunday.
- Are they?
- RuPaul's drag race, yeah.
- You're kidding!
- [Drew] I know.
- They're doing that again?
- You probably don't know about it
because you win every single year.
- Well, well.
You know, you know.
I don't do it for the Emmys,
I do it for the children, Drew.
I do it for the children, you know,
they need someplace to
go and shine and shine
and be gorgeous and fabulous and they are.
They're so gorgeous, they're so fabulous,
and we've got some real
stars up on that show
and that's just Ross Matthews.
- [Drew] Oh.
So,
one of the things that I
really loved about your journey
is that it took you a very long time
to reach the level of
success that you reached,
and I think it's something
that I'd be interested to hear
what you have to say about that to people,
because when it takes a
long time to break through,
what do you say to them to stick with it?
- Yeah, well, that's the biggest challenge
is staying interested in the work.
You know,
you started very early and
both of us are lucky enough
to have found success and
then stepped away for a minute
and then had another chance
to bite the apple again,
and that second bite is the juiciest,
it's the most delicious,
it's the most long lasting,
and you know, not many
people have that opportunity.
This is such, it's a tough business,
it's a tough business.
You have to earn it, you know,
you know, listen, it must
be even harder for you.
You come from a family, a legacy of
very famous actors in this town,
and I can only imagine how
tough for this kid to come up
and say, I want to do that too,
and then become the success you are today.
- Well, I think, you know, thank you.
I think probably adjacent
to the way you felt.
There were a lot of
misconceptions that I was born
with a silver spoon in my mouth,
or that I had doors open to me.
My family,
in 1975 and 76, when I started working,
the Barrymores at that point
were not sort of
in so much Vogue of
being the Royal family.
It had been a long time,
unfortunately, most of them had passed.
This was not like, oh, you're a Barrymore,
well come right this way.
People were like, oh yeah,
(RuPaul laughs)
The Barrymore.
And when I was born into this name,
it was a little washed up,
it was a little old school,
it was 1970s in California,
the glory days were long gone,
and I felt like I really had
to kind of break past that,
and I wonder in your childhood, you know,
what did you feel like when you were born?
Was there a predestine,
was there a support,
was there something you had
to fight against or prove?
What was it like when you were a kid?
- You know, I always knew that
there was something for me.
My mother when she was
pregnant with me saw a psychic
and the psychic said,
you're gonna have a boy
and he's going to be famous,
so I grew up with that story.
So I thought, oh, okay, well,
how am I going to do that?
I didn't know I would become
the most beautiful drag
queen in the world.
(audience cheers)
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, you know.
It's funny, it's funny, but, you know,
I knew that it was my destiny.
I didn't know how, but I was open to it,
and what we all have to do is be open
and be willing to hear the
universe's stage direction.
Your job is to find it.
Clear space for it, you
have to clear a space.
- [Drew] Now you struggled through school,
so I think it's a testament
that maybe you weren't that model student,
and yet you made it so far.
- Yeah, well, listen, you say struggle.
I say I just had no interest in it.
I was interested in being
entrepreneur, what's up Jay Z?
You know what I'm saying?
So, you know,
they don't teach you how
to be an entrepreneur.
So listen, I was just, I
was sort of wasting time.
I ended up dropping out in the 11th grade
and I learned everything I know
from reading books and
watching television, that's it
- When I got emancipated when I was 14,
the court said it is now your
choice to go to school or not,
and I said, buh-bye!
(RuPaul laughs)
I'm never going to school again,
so I never did get a high school diploma,
so you got your GED.
- I finally got my GED,
yes, when I was 19, yes.
- And I'm so incredibly excited
to announce the fact that
with Ru's support, I'm
going to be pursuing my GED
to finally finish my
traditional education.
(audience claps)
Three of our viewers are
gonna join me on this journey.
Check out this tape.
(bell rings)
- Hi, I'm Anissa Stankado.
I just turned 50 and I
live in Cape Coral, Florida
with my husband and we
have three grown children.
I was really close to
graduating, this close,
so I just needed a couple of classes,
but life got in the way.
I ended up pregnant and married at 17,
but I'm still married 32
years later to that same man.
So I haven't been able to
work for the past 10 years,
I have some health issues,
but I really feel I have more to give,
I still have more to do.
Getting my GED now will be the impetus for
my second chapter in life.
- Hi, I'm Justin Gavin.
I'm 19 years old from Brooklyn, New York.
Last year, September 9th, 2020,
I saved a family from a burning car
and that was one of the
most life-changing things
I've ever done.
It motivated me to go back to school
because I just want to make my mom proud,
my little siblings proud.
I want to be an example for them
as in no matter what you
can go through in life
you can always achieve greatness.
- Hi, my name is Linda San Miguel.
I am from San Diego, California.
I had a really tough time
in high school as it was.
I didn't have a very big support system.
I ended up dropping out
of school my junior year.
Getting my GED would just mean so much,
open up so many doors.
I really have always worried about
setting a really good
example for my children.
I just believe that you
can do this at any age,
the sky's the limit from there.
(audience claps)
- We have our very own Principal Matthews.
- [Ross Matthews] Yes, hello everybody.
It's a role I was born to play.
Seriously, you know, in
all seriousness Drew,
you are an A plus human being,
and I know you're going
to be an A plus student.
I am going to be here every
step of the way with you
and our viewers out there.
I am so proud of you, you've got this.
(audience cheers)
I love you.
- As your humble student,
happy to be in your company
and under your great tutelage.
Thank you.
- Aw, thank you, thank you!
- And I'll tell you something
because you've never let
people down in this world,
I can't let you guys down either,
so oh my god, I'm gonna be in study hall
and while I'm doing that,
you can get your fix of
RuPaul and Principal Matthews
because the full season
of Drag Race All Stars
is currently streaming on Paramount Plus,
and congratulations on
all the Emmys you've won
and all the nominations
ahead and everything.
We'll be in touch, you're gonna help me,
oh my God, here we go.
Thank you RuPaul!
(upbeat music)